[Music]
anxiety
appears to be a galloping epidemic since
its introduction as a medical condition
in the 1980s
anxiety has risen from about two percent
of cases to
being the most commonly diagnosed mental
health condition
and today it affects more than a fifth
of the population including
a third of all young people and the
covert 19 pandemic seeing
millions of people in lockdown at home
sometimes without friends or family
around them
is causing cases to soar but while it is
of course
sad that so many individuals are
struggling with feeling anxious
is the growth in anxiety simply a
rational response to deeply uncertain
times
or is it an over-medicalization of
behavior that once would have been seen
as normal or is it a consequence
of an obsessively distracted social
media culture
and importantly should we treat patients
more or will we only address the crisis
by changing our society
and its toxic culture well to discuss
this
we have three very very talented and
qualified speakers
caroline hickman has worked in mental
health and social work settings
ever since she graduated in 1983. in
2018
caroline joined the executive committee
of the climate psychology alliance
which aims do i understand the mental
roadblocks we face when trying to tackle
the climate crisis then former drugs are
david nutt
is a leading authority on drugs
addiction and anxiety
and has made the newspapers on multiple
occasions for claims such as
taking ecstasy is less dangerous than
rioting a horse and
alcohol is more harmful than heroin
and mark salter is a consultant in adult
psychiatry
for the nhs he's currently the media
expert for the royal college of
psychiatrists
and is vocal about the need for a reform
to the uk's approach
to mental health so three fantastically
qualified speakers there
and we're going to be addressing overall
the topic of is the anxiety
epidemic a rational response to
modern times and to start that
we are going to have three minutes from
each of our speakers
who will give us their thoughts on why
precisely we should take their point of
view
i'm going to start for our first three
minutes with caroline hickman
thank you so i'm going to be presenting
a psychotherapeutic perspective on
anxiety
as a psychotherapist doing research with
children and young people into how they
feel about
climate change and the biodiversity
crisis
and increasingly inevitably about the
current virus and pandemic
so i'm going to be arguing that anxiety
is part of life it's the price we pay
for being alive awake and aware in the
world
and we often i think emotionally have a
choice between depression
and anxiety depression if we go inwards
and don't go out into the world and take
risks
as soon as we go out into the world and
face the unknown and start to take risks
we will often start to feel anxiety but
one of the problems we've got with that
is we treat it like it's an unwelcome
guest we want to get rid of it because
it makes us feel really uncomfortable
so we don't want to listen to the
message that the anxiety
is bringing to us so it goes away and
sulks and then comes back again
so we can end up living our lives in the
battle between trying to get rid of
anxiety
trying to tolerate it or just being
overwhelmed by it
so i'm going to be arguing that actually
we need to change our relationship with
it
and we need to listen to the messages
that it's bringing we need to listen
to the wisdom and maybe there is a point
to this anxiety
because certainly at the moment there
are things out there in the world the
origins of our anxiety
whether it's virus or climate change or
biodiversity crisis
which should make us feel anxious
because they are genuine threats
so do we want to fight them or run away
from them or do we freeze or do we lie
to ourselves about them
or do we accept that these anxieties
that have been provoked at the moment
might make perfect sense and actually
what we should be doing is trying to
listen to them
and adjust in our relationship to them
because that way we might be able to
find
a wise relationship with our anxiety we
might be able to develop more emotional
psychological resilience which will help
us to face
the looming crisis when we're through
the current pandemic of the climate and
biodiversity crisis
and that's often what children and young
people are communicating about
when they're saying how anxious and
afraid and angry they are
that we're not listening to the science
we're not taking action on the climate
crisis
we worry about children and young
people's anxieties but actually we also
need to be thinking
about the fact that we're not taking
action to reduce the cause of those
anxieties
by taking action on climate change so
what these children and young people are
doing is they're somehow embodying our
vulnerability
they're embodying for us the
vulnerability that we might be all be
feeling at the moment
as we move into this uncertain world so
i don't want us to defend against our
feelings of anxiety
i don't want us to suppress them i don't
want us to get rid of them
i want us to listen to them and not just
allow these feelings any of those things
will just make it worse
and as i said it'll come back our
anxiety for me
is a sign that we care and that we're
alive and we're awake
and we need to pay attention to that
it's a sign of empathy
without empathy and that compassion both
for ourselves and for others
particularly with these global crises
that we're dealing with now
we would not be alive or awake or
engaged as human beings
caroline thank you very much indeed for
a very thoughtful and very concise
pitch to start us off with could i now
turn for our next pitch to david nutt
thank you so um as you heard i'm a
psychiatrist and uh
most of my professional career i have
been treating people with anxiety
disorders i set up a specialist clinic
in bristol many years ago and one of the
reasons i got interested in drugs and
drug abuse
because i saw that many of the drugs
which people use
to deal with anxiety like alcohol can
actually turn into problems of
dependence
and that overlap between the
psychological experience of anxiety and
the pharmacological interactions
that people use to modulate it is
interesting for a number of levels it's
interesting because it
can produce problems rarely does
you solve the problem of alcohol by
turning to something like alcohol
but it also raises fascinating questions
of neuroscience which is an
area i have long been interested in
we can explore the brain mechanisms of
anxiety
by making inferences about the drugs
which people use to deal with exert
and what is actually clear is that there
is a brain substrate for anxiety which
turns out to be both adaptive and
maladaptive
as you've heard already that anxiety is
necessary you're not anxious you
quite often wouldn't get up and go to
work or turn out for your
exams or your driving test or whatever
that is a motivating
phenomenon but there are times when it
gets to a state when
it exceeds motivation and it becomes
destructive and damaging to people's
function
and that's a maladaptive level of
arousal some people used to call it
morbid anxiety
one of the most fascinating things is
that for some people they just can
happen
you know i have many examples of
patients of mine who have just one day
woken up with this
overwhelming sense of dread it was
focused on nothing at all
and it seems very much a sort of
internal kind of construct
so anxiety is a multifaceted phenomenon
and it's driven in part by uncertainty
about the world and in part it's
underpinned by biological changes in the
body and the brain
and we have to look at all of those to
make sense of what's happening and also
of course to work out how best to deal
with it david thank you very much indeed
very very clearly put
and let me turn for the third pitch to
mark salter
thank you i think there's something very
revealing about the title of this debate
we're talking about anxiety like it's a
thing in fact like it's a kind of fungus
that must be eradicated at all costs a
disease
but it's more than that it's not a thing
it's a process
and another thing is that the words got
the word the title's got the word
rational
in it there's nothing really that
rational about anxiety in fact it's
important because
anxiety switches off rationality and
that's a very important point
what anxiety is is a process and it's a
mechanism and here's
i think a killer point it is common to
every
living thing on this planet you can just
certain anxiety in the behavior of
bacteria
of a bee the tree even
and i'm not looking about that and what
it does basically
is it is a situation that's been
confirmed upon us by 1.4
billion years of life i.e evolution
to actually be on the constant lookout
for things we talk about
fight or flight mechanisms that's only a
fraction of it
what really happens is that we are
constantly monitoring one part of our
brain
every single thing that is happening in
us inside
and around us outside at the minute
there's a discrepancy
there's an anomaly a mechanism switches
on that says oh
and you homing on it your body will
evaluate it in a nano
second far faster than a human thought
could ever go
and if it's significant it will divert
all the resources of the human brain
towards it
it will switch off every unwanted app
including rational
thought and it will make us take action
and it's not just flight or fight
it's freeze and it's faff now
this mechanism has served us pretty well
for the hundred thousand years that
we've been on this planet which is not
very long
we'd have quite simple lives we hunted
we gathered it was sex and
saber-toothed tigers for the most most
of it but in the last
5 000 years something bad has happened i
don't think it's that good at all okay
get a bit of a near miss with
rationalism of the greeks and the
indians and the chinese in the um
pre-christian era but around 500 years
ago
a frenchman said a very silly thing he
said i think
therefore i am basically he blew out the
water the idea that human beings are
anything other than rational so it was
goodbye nature goodbye human nature
goodbye kindness goodbye emotion
hello algorithm hello science hello
factories hello pollution have no agreed
hello market forces and as the years
have gone by
and what we've seen increasingly is that
we're getting busier and busier
we are poisoning ourselves to death we
are drinking the water we are hogging
the oxygen
we are robbing the commonwealth of this
planet and that is becoming increasingly
clear to us in many many ways this virus
included
meanwhile that quietly ticking alarm
clock in our body that alarm system is
detecting all this
and it is going off more and more
because we're giving it more and more
information to continue watching this
video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas